let me pull up this story here from uh
the post-millennial big fans New York
City to pay out $53 million on prepaid
debit cards to illegal immigrants in
pilot program oh uh so when Eric Adams
comes out and says this will destroy us
he gets accused of crimes and he gets
raided the next thing you know he's like
I am going to give $53 million to
illegal immigrants I am totally for this
it's it's coming out of my bank account
too he's like blinking out in moris code
like I don't want to rescue me no it's
bad I think it' be funnier if they spent
$53 million to just ship them to Eagle
Pass at which point they're escorted
back across the border I I genuinely
think the Democrats strategy is we have
to destroy this country to the greatest
degree imaginable before Trump wins
because the only response we have or I
should say not the only but the
functional response the best course of
action is Trump wins so I think you know
there's uh I just love all of the
articles that are popping up about
Taylor Swift I'm not going to get into
the whole thing about Taylor Swift my
point is this have any of the people
who' have pushed that story stopped to
ask themselves why it is the corporate
press is running Full Speed Ahead
pumping out dozens of stories about the
right attacking Taylor
Swift they they they want you to they
want you to do this okay don't why is it
we look at
this I I I I think there their attitude
is like they're desperately praying some
right-winger Maga guy acts a fool mhm
they want they want some right-wing guy
to act out of line so they can use that
and so they're going to press and turn
the heat up in the pressure cooker as
much as possible $53 million of your
money going to illegal immigrants the
Border crisis like the CBP cutting
border barrier razor wire like why are
they doing this obviously they want to
destroy the country but I think they're
trying to force or actually create the
circumstances where they can at least
claim the right engagement kind of
violence I think we're we're seeing this
like sustained absurdity and it's and
they're becoming very desperate and uh
this is about to be dark so if you have
little ones listening uh it's dark but
this is how I've been thinking about the
government lately in terms of their
desperation I think of Ted Bundy and how
T Bundy operated secretly for years you
know doing horrible things and his last
Act of desperation when they were on to
him went on a horrible murder spree you
know and it seems like with this kind of
sustained absurdity and and violence and
the war on every front possible it seems
like you know I think of the government
like Ted Bundy in that last desper act
it it may be like for him he said oh no
they're going to catch me I better get
as much as I can in for the Democrats
and the uni party I think they're
thinking we like Trump is going to
reverse whatever it is we do let's so so
imagine it this way let's say there's a
scale of uh Z to 100 and they're like if
we're at 50 Trump is going to pull them
pull us back to 20 we need to push
things to 100 so Trump can only go back
to 70 so it's like they know that
Trump's going to deport a million
migrants left Works destroy everything
migrants let's bring in 10 million so he
can only Deport one out of the nine we
got in it's a big ask like in terms of
yeah policiy and it has two effects
number one they can run screaming with
all these headlines being like how could
he do this he's deporting poor Asylum
Seekers and etc etc and also they can
then say and he didn't even do that good
of a job there are so many more people
here he didn't come through with his
promises like they're trying to set him
up to fail on two fronts which is crazy
it's the inverse of what Biden did with
the economy coming back after uh Trump
locking it down so they keep claiming
all these jobs came back but they came
back because we took them away right and
then they spin that as a positive for
Biden so it'll be the inverse of that
for Trump when they make it they wreck
this country so much and it's like
almost impossible to bring it back to
the way it was you know I think we're
missing the bigger point is like Joe
they're now trying to set up Joe Biden
as a wartime president you know
single-handedly La pressing the buttons
of hundreds of missiles into the Middle
East meanwhile he's back in bed in
Delaware I think right now right like he
spend most they released like a three
paragraph statement and typically the
president's supposed to get up there and
give a speech to explain to the American
people now it's just on autopilot I
don't think they're trying to make him a
wartime president because like I like
you said he should be up there standing
giving speeches and he's not I think
they're it's part of the big we'll call
the big act not the big ask where
they're saying if Trump gets elected
he's pulling our out of all these places
let's scattershot the Middle East
forcing military action on the United
States that Trump could never even pull
back from so bring in 10x illegal
immigrants so Trump can only Deport half
of them go to war as much as possible in
the Middle East so that Trump will
struggle to get our troops out they're
just trying to create the biggest mess
for Trump to clean up so it looks like
he's not succeeding no no they're trying
to get four they're trying to get eight
years of the presidency in four years
crazy so that when Trump goes in and and
actually I say 12 years because Trump's
going to reverse four years of their
actions they want eight they want 2020
to 2028 everything they want illegal
immigration War conflict crisis if Trump
is minus four years they need to do 12
12 years of this policy happening in
four years and that makes sense if you
think about it 10 million illegal
immigrants in in in in the span of a
couple years right if they had if they
had the uh if they had the White House
up until 2028 they can be like well we
can sustain it slowly but they genuinely
think Trump's going to win most people
think Trump's going to win so they're
like we have to Triple our efforts so
that Trump can only pull back a little
bit but that allows them to accomplish
their goals from now until 2028 yep I
I've been calling them uh these things
in the sto in the in the media like
invisible landmines where there's
something that you know that the all the
migrants are criminals fugitives The
Invasion is happening and then they're
filling the country Trump takes over
then they turn him into the bad guy by
saying look he's doing all these crazy
things he's he's deporting everyone he's
the monster whe always told you he was
they're going to show pictures of him
like people are being loaded into trucks
and buses and they're going to say we
said never again but it's happening no
yeah think of all the New Yorker covers
they're going to paint him you know
looking like like Hitler and whatnot but
well maybe he should be more strategic
maybe just uh start by deporting the
child molesters and the drunk drivers
but that's not going to matter for the
assaulters right it's not going to
matter for the photographs and the
propaganda so the smart play is that he
has to deport them in a way that makes
it difficult for them to run that
narrative and I actually think that
hopefully conservative Med gets out with
him cuz I think that's part of it they
they can't back down and use the terms
they have to be honest about the fact
that these people are always here
illegally and they're not supposed to be
here I no I think the the the answer I I
brought this up the other day is uh
Donald Trump gets in immediately goes I
agree with dick Durban we're going to
bring them into the military good men
and women in uniform and then you take
all the illegal immigrants so you you
you with hand shakes and a salute we're
like you're coming to basic training and
then through all this you know they'll
post a photo on a magazine being like
Trump is enlisting illegal immigrants I
guess it's like well a Democrat idea and
they may try to spin it but then what
you what you do is you
de hold on hold on you deploy them wink
oh all right so what country are you
from sir I'm from Honduras
congratulations you're being deployed to
Honduras
you don't need a gun or a
helmet here's that more expensive route
to do this but we're going to we're
going to send you to the other side of
the border to guard the Border we'll
take them that's a good idea stay over
there don't let anybody in wait that's a
good idea actually you're all being
deployed to line the Border uh don't let
anybody in who needs a wall we have a
human wall if anybody gets in none of
you get citizenship
yeah if you could hold it for a year but
then the best part years but the best
part is we can promise them anything and
like the US government already treats
its veterans they just abandoned them
yeah right we give you nothing there you
go it's like uh I served for 4 years
it's like do you notice the the line of
all the other veterans that we've
ignored man you should have read the
fine print I think that's true maybe
this is the way to solve this issue I
was skeptical at first because it seemed
like we'd just be using taxpayer money
to do something crazy but well it that's
the only way to secure the Border but
then but then when the media is like
Trump is loading up all these people on
the buses and trains and then he's like
but yeah because they chose to join the
military cuz they're good people why why
would you insult them like that oh jeez
and of course the training camp is a new
training camp we've set up in um
southern Mexico this is getting very
Roman Empire riew
Tim I mean that's what you could do like
basic training for all uh non-citizens
who want to enlist we uh well that that
training camp is not in the United
States it's uh you know in Guatemala
right we exported our training
facilities to Mexico it's cheaper there
just like
we're saving money for everybody yeah
and then we just you know your your your
your job is to guard the training camp
and they all just stay there problem
solved be interesting but yeah you'll
need Creative Solutions otherwise
they're going to run this narrative
Donald Trump is Hitler I mean I gota be
honest like they've already run that
narrative ad nauseum yeah they'll add
photos to the mix I wonder if at that
point everyone's going to be like just I
just don't care anymore you know like
apathy Central well no look I mean this
might be the best thing in the world for
Trump trump finally gets in actually is
loading people on buses and trains and
sending them off to be deported and the
media screams he's Hitler and at that
point you're like I get it the sky is
falling and there's wolves I don't care
I'm so over it well I think the thing is
if they run the pictures of trump
loading people up on buses because you
know why would he Deport people who are
illegally apparently that's the wrong
thing to do I think hopefully
conservative media Gets behind him and
and runs the photos of every person who
has been killed by someone who was here
illegally I mean there are already
resources that do this border Hawk does
this D Dan Lyman there are people who
suffer because of immigration not just
the economic effects but like the crime
if you showed all the footage of the you
saw this the trash and like the
underwear that's at the border right
there's horrible things there's evidence
that something is wrong and we just
don't show those pictures enough it's
that like republicans in Congress the
media that supports Trump or the
influencers let's say the the spokes the
the talking heads that to it need to be
just as on the offense I I think I
figured it out I know what we need you
remember that article where it said it
was like um Trump ends up supporting
lockdown so that everyone opposes or
something like that what we need is 5D
chess where Trump gets elected but keeps
doing everything the Democrats want to
be done and so they have no choice but
to oppose all of it so but here here's
prepaid debit cards pilot program that's
a first action first action of business
Donald Trump gets in and he's like we're
going to open the Border let everybody
in and the Democrat are immediately like
uh we got a bill through Congress and no
more border and he's like I guess I have
to sign it and then he signs it and then
he's like we're going to send all our
troops to to Iran like no no we you
can't do that yeah Trump's a fascist
like oh jeez I guess I got okay no
troops to Iran might be the only way to
do it because the Republicans even when
we had he had Congress and Senate in
that first two years not much was done
and and the Democrats do mobilize so you
got to trick them do you feel like the
there's been a changing of the guards in
that in the house and in in the Senate
with the Republicans that are there I
feel like after the last year we've
really seen a sort of uh Clashing of old
and new I would say thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net